gebrill und Geschrei mittlerweile Alltag
die ab die Politik hat ein
Akzeptanzproblem wenn die Politik nicht
sofort die Menschen bei ihren Sorgen
Ängsten und Nöten ernst nimmt dann
fliegt uns der ganze Laden um die Uhren
das sind jetzt die letzten Jahre in
denen wir die Zukunft von uns als
Menschheit bestimmen können die Politik
versagt
einfach nun sollen die Bürger selber ran
160 von ihnen hat der Bundestag
eingeladen in seinen ersten Bürgerrat
wenn dieser Weg dazu beiträgt dass auch
vielleicht die Kluft miteinander wieder
zu einem respektvollen Ton zu kommen
hilft ist das glaube ich auch ein guter
Start das mit bürgerrittenen zu machen
ich sehe hier auch eine nicht
unproblematische Entwicklung von
staatswegen auf die Meinungsbildung in
der Gesellschaft einzuwirken Thorsten
Winkler Hausmeister in Franken hat im
Juni Post bekommen wieder so ein
Werbebrief dachte er
zunächst sehr geehrter Herr Winkler sie
wurden im Auftrag des Deutschen
Bundestags ausgelost melden Sie sich für
die sogenannte bürgerlotterie an und so
sitzt er wenig später vor seinem
Computer ausgelost wird deutschlands
erster Bürgerrat Winkler ist im Topf ja
es ist halt wie bei einer Lotterie
gewesen wo man am Samstagabend Halt hat
und
es war halt wieer Glückslos dann ne
jetzt wird die
erste Ziffer
gezogen Bundestagspräsidentin berbel B
gibt die Lottofee gelost werden vorher
zusammengestellte bürgerratsgruppen die
repräsentativ für ganz Deutschland sein
sollen das alles geht auf Initiative von
cludiniert und ihren Verein mehr
Demokratie zurück wir haben ja heute das
Problem dass die Bürger und Bürger am
Spielfeld ran stehen und alles besser
wissen brüllen Sch
protestieren und sagen wenn ich auf dem
Feld wäre aber wenn man sie mal wirklich
aufs Feld lässt und sie in die
Verantwortung der Spielführung kommt
dann verändert sich die Position
sofort seit Jahren kämpft die
ausgebildete Tänzerin für mehr
Bürgerbeteiligung hat zahlreiche
Volksentscheide mit
initiiert je größer die Reform und je
unbequemer das Thema ist desto mehr
müssen sie eigentlich die Bevölkerung
mit einbeziehen die heiklen Themen
können Sie nie gegen die Bevölkerung
sondern nur mit
voranbringen dann sage ich Ihnen
herzlich willkommen Bürgerrat das Thema
des bürgerrats die Ernährung haben die
Regierungsfraktionen vorgegeben derzeit
wirklich das Thema das die Gesellschaft
spaltet was viele hier ein sie finden
sich in der derzeitigen Politik nur
bedingt wieder momentan sind wir bei
einer Politik mit ihr müsst ihr sollt
ihr dürft selber entscheiden momentan
läuft aus meiner Sicht so ab und ich wä
echt blöd wenn mir jetzt ano aufbrum
kriegen ihr müsst vegetarisch leben
warum sollen wir das nicht selber
entscheiden die 160 Bürger sollen
Deutschland im kleinen darstellen dabei
habe nicht nur das Los sondern auch
künstliche Intelligenz geholfen so
Bundestagspräsidentin berbelbs sagen Sie
was Sie denken und reden Sie wie Sie
immer reden die berühmte schweigende
Masse ich weiß nicht was sie denkt so
und dieser Bürgerrat bietet jetzt die
Chance auch dieser sogenannten
schweigenden bitte einfach auch eine
Stimme zu geben indem sie z miteinander
diskutieren diese Art der
Bürgerbeteiligung findet die CDU CSU
keine gute Idee philip amtor ist in der
Fraktion für Staatsmodernisierung
zuständig wenn man sagt ja der Bürgerrat
der hätte dann jetzt also die Wahrheit
der Meinung der Bürger und das was die
gewählten Politiker da erzählen und
diskutieren das hat mit der Realität der
Bürger ja nicht zu tun das hielte ich
für eine wirklich gefährliche
Beschreibung auch weil es natürlich
schon die Grundsätze unserer
repräsentativen Demokratie relativiert
die letzte Generation findet genau diese
repräsentative Demokratie habe versagt
sie fordert die sofortige Einrichtung
von bürgerräten zur Klimafrage ich
glaube dass über diese Räte eine viel
bessere Präsentation der der Bevölkerung
erzielt wird also im Bundestag sitzen
fünf Menschen die kein Abitur gemacht
haben das sieht in der Bevölkerung
sicherlich anders aus ihre Forderung
wollen die klimaaktivisten erzwingen
seit Monaten sorgen sie für Staus und
Wut um die Menschheit zu retten wie sie
sagen wenn ihr sogenannter
gesellschaftsrat eingerichtet sei müsse
es TV Brennpunkte und Titelseiten geben
und die Bundesregierung solle
versprechen die Beschlüsse auch eins
zuins
umzusetzen das was der gesellschaftsrat
erarbeitet würde nahzu alle Bereiche
unseres Lebens betreffen das wäre wie
gesagt Verkehr das wäre sicherlich auch
die Art und Weise wie wir bauen das ist
die Art und Weise wie wir Nahrungsmittel
produzieren was dann daraus resultiert
was wir sehr wahrscheinlich Essen werden
und so weiter und so fort natürlich
fordern die einen oder anderen aus der
Zivilgesellschaft wir brauchen dazu
einen Rat unbedingt ja meistens weil sie
sich erhoffen dass der Rat die Frage so
beantwortet wie Sie sie als
zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation
beantwortet sehen wollen dafür brauchen
Sie kein Bürgerrat machen ein Bürgerrat
macht Sinn wenn ich die Antwort nicht
weiß
ein großes Hotel hat die
Bundestagspräsidentin anmieten lassen im
Keller neben dem Parkhaus wird nun
getagt ein ganzes Wochenende soll der
Staat Einfluss auf die
Ernährungsgewohnheiten seiner Bürger
nehmen ein Warmup soll die erst einmal
wach machen dann folgen
Expertenvorträge es soll ja der
Bürgerrat begleitet werden von
Experten die wiederum von einem
Sachverständigen Beirat glaube ich
ausgewählt werden der wiederum benannt
wird von den Fraktionen also hier zeigen
sich doch ja gewisse staatliche
Einflussmöglichkeiten darauf wie der
Bürgerrat wie er beraten wird mit
welcher Tendenz er tätig wird
Staatsrechtler Christoph Degenhard lehnt
bürgerräte nicht grundsätzlich ab doch
so wie in Deutschland organisiert seinen
sie zahnlose Tiger anders in Irland da
folgten auf das Jahr des bürgerrats zur
geschlechtlichen Ehe und der Aufhebung
des abtreibungsverbots Volksentscheide
die Mehrheit der Bürger stimmte zu die
Partei die Grünen hatten ja stets die
direkte Demokratie Volksabstimmungen in
ihrem
Grundsatzprogramm und als jetzt die Wahl
die Macht in greifbare Nähe gerückt war
vor der letzten Bundestagswahl haben sie
es Fluchs aus ihrem Grundsatzprogramm
gestrichen und stattdessen die
bürgerräte aufgenommen die halt weniger
Probleme machen können und weniger Ärger
verursachen denn bei Abstimmungen hat
man immer das Problem ja dass das Volk
nicht immer so abstimmt wie man will und
bei bürgerräten an deren Ergebnisse ist
mer nicht
gebunden bis Februar
2024 sollen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sich auf neun Empfehlungen an die
Politik einigen was sie bis dahin
untereinander diskutieren darüber dürfen
sie aber nicht sprechen in einem separat
Raum wurden Boxen eingerichtet für die
Arbeit in Kleingruppen Presse ist nicht
zugelassen und die letzte Generation sie
wird weiter mit Sekundenkleber die
Autofahrer blockieren will erst aufhören
wenn ihr gesellschaftsrat eingerichtet
ist und dessen Maßnahmen von der
Bundesregierung auch umgesetzt wurden